The designer of Saddam Hussein's bunker was
the grandson of the woman who built Adolf
Hitler's bunker.
The human brain takes in 11 million bits of
information every second, but is only aware
of 40 of them.
98% of British homes have carpeted floors.
But in Italy, only 2% do.
All of the words written on Twitter every
day would fill a 10-million-page book.
A burning candle creates 1.5 million tiny
diamonds per second.
People earning over £14,000 a year are amongst
the richest 4% on the planet.
The ancient Greeks had no word for religion.
Italy's biggest business is the Mafia.
It turns over $178 billion a year and accounts
for 7% of the country's GDP.
Kangaroos, koalas, wombats and Tasmanian devils
all have three vaginas.
In the 17th century, the salary of the Governor
of Barbados was paid in sugar.
Worldwide sales of cocaine earn more than
Microsoft, McDonald's and Kellogg's combined.